und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend das
dürfte wieder ein ziemlich langer Abend
werden nächsten Mittwoch im Kanzleramt
die Ministerpräsidenten und
Präsidentinnen der Länder sind geladen
das Thema ist heikel die Stimmung
gereizt und der eine der andere hat auch
noch einen Wahlkampf vor Augen in Hessen
etwa wo auch bundesinnenministerin väser
antreten wird
angesichts der wieder gestiegenen
Flüchtlingszahlen klagen die Länder über
mangelnde Unterstützung vom Bund die
Berliner Ampelkoalition ist sich
zumindest in der Hinsicht aber einig
dass sie schon sehr vielen Unterstützung
zahle für Unterbringung und Versorgung
geflüchtet haben das lassen die Länder
aber so nicht gelten berichtet Patricia
Wiedemeier
die Fronten vor dem migrationsgipfel am
Mittwoch im Kanzleramt sie sind
verhärtet ich glaube in Berlin ignoriert
man was insbesondere in den Kommunen was
praktisch vor Ort los ist ich erwarte
dass der Bund sich nicht mit uns
streitet das wäre sehr schädlich ich
glaube es ist insgesamt nicht gut wenn
wir über Monate hinweg in dieser
Hinsicht ein offene
Meinungsverschiedenheit zwischen Bund
und Ländern haben
parteiübergreifend fordern die Länder
mehr Geld vom Bund und schlagen Alarm
die Unterkünfte sind übervoll wie im
hessischen Groß-Rohrheim oder in
Bensheim Länder und Kommunen überfordert
die Flüchtlingszahlen steigen weiter an
die Länder sie fühlen sich allein
gelassen vom Bund wir sind entschieden
der Auffassung wir brauchen ein
adminesssystem ein System das die
Mitverantwortung des Bundes vor allen
Dingen auch anhand der Zahlen von
Menschen steuert die zu uns kommen
es kann nicht damit getan sein dass über
jahrespauschalleistung ganz unabhängig
von der Zahl der Schutz suchenden der
Bund meint er könne in dieser Hinsicht
seine Aufgabe erledigt haben das ist
ziemlich verstörend wenn man weiß dass
wir eigentlich eine gemeinsame
Verantwortung haben der Bund gibt uns in
Nordrhein-Westfalen in diesem Jahr 600
Millionen Euro wir haben Gesamtkosten
von 3,7 Milliarden Euro gegeben allein
1,8 Milliarden Euro an die Kommunen
weiter also der Bund tut wirklich nicht
das allermeiste
zudem müsse die Zahl der Flüchtlinge
insgesamt begrenzt werden nur der Bund
nicht die Länder könne für
Grenzsicherung in Deutschland in Europa
aber auch für Fortschritte bei
Rücknahmeabkommen sorgen
wir schützen viele Menschen nehmen viele
Menschen auf aber wir sind auch
praktisch an der Grenze es geht um
Wohnraum Kita und Schulplätze und da
muss eben auch der Bund helfen
finanziell und zum anderen muss der Bund
stärker steuern indem eben auch die
Menschen die keinen Bleiberecht haben
wie z.B Straftäter besser zurückgeführt
werden wie so oft vor solchen Gipfeln
erhöhen beide Seiten den Druck der Bund
gibt bisher jedoch bei den finanziellen
Forderungen nicht nach es dürften
äußerst schwierige Gespräche werden
bundesinnenministerin ferser setzt
darauf die Zahl der Einreisenden
Flüchtlinge zu begrenzen auf die die
wirklich Aussicht auf Asyl haben oder
als Kriegsflüchtlinge anerkannt sind
kämen weniger Asylbewerber die man erst
unterbringen und dann wieder abschieben
muss gäbe es weniger Probleme weniger
kosten das sei ihr Vorgänger Horst
Seehofer ähnlich der damit am Ende aber
wie schon andere vor ihm an der
Zerstrittenheit der Europäischen Union
scheiterte Caesar zeigt sich aber
hoffnungsfroh dass es diesmal klappen
könnte sie plädiert auch für Asylzentren
an den EU-Außengrenzen mit schnelleren
Entscheidungsverfahren und besserem
Grenzschutz notfalls auch mit mehr
Zäunen wie die FDP sie fordert Zäune
nutzen allerdings wenig wenn flüchtende
übers Meer kommen bereit ihr Leben zu
riskieren und fröller berichtet
an diesem Wochenende ist Tag der offenen
Tür in Brüssel so präsentiert sich
Europa gerne als ein Ort der jeden
willkommen heißt und das ist das andere
Gesicht Europas das hässliche das
Mittelmeer als Massengrab allein in
diesem Jahr sind schon wieder mehr als
800 Flüchtlinge ertrunken private
Seenotretter wie SOS humanity versuchen
Leben zu schützen auch weil Europa
wegschaut
es ist nicht nur aus meiner Sicht
moralisch verwerflich Menschen so
abzuweisen und sehenden Auges zum
Beispiel ertrinken zu lassen im
Mittelmeer es ist eben auch rechtlich
nicht haltbar und Europa macht sich
unglaubwürdig die Flüchtlinge kommen
unter anderem aus Afghanistan aus Syrien
aus Pakistan Europa kennt vor allem eine
Reaktion Abschottung baut Zäune aus wie
hier an der ungarisch serbischen Grenze
oder bestaunt demonstrativ Grenzanlagen
wie Österreichs Bundeskanzler nehammer
der einen schwerwiegenden Satz
formuliert
wir müssen endlich Weiterkommen dass
Asylsystem in Europa ist gescheitert
auch die Deutschen wissen das
unkontrollieren ihre Grenzen was in
Gefahr ist ist unser Schengenraum
nämlich ein Europa der offenen Grenzen
wenn wir das jetzt nicht hinbekommen
dann wird es dazu führen dass die
Mitgliedsstaaten wieder verstärkt bin
ganz Kontrollen machen und das ist nicht
der Gedanke der Europäischen Union die
Regierungschefs sind zerstritten das
sind die Hardliner angeführt vom
ungarischen Regierungschef Orban die
überhaupt keine Asylbewerber und
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen wollen und jeden
Kompromiss boykottieren da ist die
italienische Regierungschefin Meloni die
eine gerechtere Verteilung der
Flüchtlinge fordert da ist der deutsche
Bundeskanzler der auf schärfere
Kontrollen an der EU Außengrenze und
schnellere Asylverfahren pocht und das
sind viele grüne den das zu weit geht
wir bauen ja überall Zäune seit Jahren
der Schotten uns ja immer weiter ab und
trotzdem reden wir dann jedes Jahr
wieder so als gäbe es neue
migrationskrise das ist aber einfach die
Krise die hausgemacht ist um das zu
verhindern wärmen die Regierungschefs
eine alte Idee auf flüchtlingsabkommen
die sollen nun mit Tunesien und Marokko
geschlossen werden die Länder sollen
Milliarden bekommen und lassen dafür nur
noch wenige Flüchtlinge nach Europa
durch bisher hat diese Idee nicht
funktioniert ich glaube dass die
Koalition einen anderen Ansatz hat in
der Migrationspolitik nämlich für
migrationsabkommen zu sorgen etwas
anzubieten nämlich mega Fluchtwege nach
Deutschland mit der Möglichkeit in
Deutschland zu arbeiten und auf der
anderen Seite dann auch die
Verpflichtung der Rücknahme Europa sucht
wieder einmal nach einer Antwort und
während sich die Regierungschefs nicht
einigen können treiben die Flüchtlinge
im Meer
der Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus ist
und zugeschaltet der auch Regierungen
bei diesen flüchtlingsfragen schon
beraten hat guten Abend Herr Knaus guten
Abend diese migrationsabkommen auf die
jetzt Frau Felser die EU setzt ist das
ein erfolgversprechender weg
es ist sehr schwierig darüber darf man
keine Illusionen haben
aber es ist alternativlos wenn man nicht
will dass in diesem Jahr wieder tausende
Menschen sterben und wenn man nicht will
dass ich die in der EU durchsetzen die
auf Gewalt setzen also auf das
zurückstoßen von Booten entgegen
internationalen Recht aber wir haben
auch gesehen zum Beispiel Überblick auf
das türkei-abkommen das im Prinzip
ziemlich tot jetzt ist wie fragil solche
bilateralen Abkommen mit Regierungen
sind die auch nicht immer unbedingt von
den demokratischen gehören sondern in
Tunesien oder Ägypten denkt irgendwie
ist das jetzt auch nicht gerade die
Gesprächspartner die man sich wünscht ja
absolut und was wir gelernt haben und
wir haben viel gelernt von der Türkei
Erklärung ist dass es darum geht auch
Interessen zu schaffen auf auf beiden
Seiten die dazu führen dass die andere
Seite das andere Land tatsächlich sich
an diese Abkommen halten will im Falle
der Türkei hat das vierjährige dauert
dann hat die EU nicht mehr klar gemacht
dass sie bereit ist die große Zahl in
der Türkei finanziell zu unterstützen
und daraufhin hat die Türkei von sich
aus das Abkommen de facto ausgesetzt
also wenn man mit Tunesien wenn man mit
der Türkei wenn man mit Marokko über
solche Abkommen spricht dann ist es
sinnvoll Dinge anzubieten die im
Interesse des anderen Landes sind so
sehr dass die Regierungen die Abkommen
nicht einfach aufgeben können zum
Beispiel legale
arbeitsmigrationsmöglichkeiten
Erleichterungen bei der Visa Vergabe
vielleicht sogar die Aussicht auf Visa
Liberalisierung wenn diese Länder die
Menschenrechte und andere Bedingungen
erfüllen und solche Versprechen führen
dann dazu dass die Politik in diesen
Ländern und das sehen wir am Balkan das
sehen wir anders wo ein Interesse haben
Versprechen auch einzuhalten ein anderer
Vorschlag haben zählt auf Asylzentren
schon an den Außengrenzen der EU mit
schnelleren abschiebeverfahren für jene
die sowieso keine Aussicht hätten oder
nur geringe Aussichten gibt es einige
Länder wo eigentlich die meisten immer
wieder abgeschoben werden marokko ist so
ein Beispiel was halten Sie von diesem
gesagt dass man eben die Menschen gar
nicht erst quasi in den Schengenraum
einreisen lässt
ja also das Problem an diesem Vorschlag
ist dass er ohne die migrationsabkommen
und die Zusicherung dass Menschen nach
einem schnellen und fairen Verfahren
auch zurückgenommen werden
ganz sicherlich nicht umgesetzt wird
denn wieder Spanien nach Italien haben
ein Interesse dass wenn eine größere
Zahl wie in den letzten Jahren aus
Tunesien oder Marokko in Irland kommen
dass sie die einfach an der Grenze
festhalten ohne eine Zusage was danach
diesen Verfahren passieren wird und so
gesehen bedingen sich diese beiden Dinge
ohne migrationsabkommen bringen auch
schnelle Verfahren an der Grenze nichts
aber da sind dann eben einige EU-Länder
auch nicht bereit aufzunehmen für die
die Chancen auf Asyl hätten und die
werden jetzt im Moment im Prinzip
durchgewunken und dann landet ein großer
Teil eben nur in bestimmten Länder ja
absolut und daher ist es auch wichtig
realistisch zu sein aber um es
einzuordnen im letzten Jahr hatten wir
ungefähr 160.000 Menschen über das
gesamte Mittelmeer gekommen sind Spanien
Italien Griechenland Malta Zypern und
sehr viele davon kamen eben aus Ländern
mit einer sehr geringen Anerkennung
Chance eben Tunesien Marokko Ägypten
Bangladesch und da könnten kluge
migrationsabkommen mit Interessen auf
beiden Seiten die Zahl der Menschen die
sich überhaupt den Boote setzen stark
reduzieren und das ist in diesem Jahr
dringend notwendig denn sonst wird das
eines der blutigsten und tödlichsten
Jahre Mittelmeer nach dem was wir in den
letzten drei Monaten schon gesehen haben
Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus danke
für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
die Türkei ist natürlich nicht nur wegen
des eben erwähnten flüchtlingsabkommens
für Europa insgesamt und besonders für
Deutschland wichtig es hat Auswirkungen
auf uns wer die Türkei regiert und wie
sie regiert wird sie ist dazu Mitglied
sie ist Handelspartner und es leben in
Deutschland fast 3 Millionen Menschen
mit türkischen Familienwurzeln und die
Hälfte davon ist bei den türkischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen nächsten Sonntag
wahlberechtigtheit erdogan ist nun schon
seit 20 Jahren an der Macht und sein
regieren würde immer autoischem
unangefochten blieb er trotzdem doch
diesmal muss er um einen erneuten Sieg
bangen die Unzufriedenheit im Land ist
groß und sein gegen Kandidat hat es
geschafft ein breites Bündnis zu
schmieden Jörg braase porträtiert
der Herausforderer betritt die Bühne
gestern Abend in Istanbul Kemal Kilic
der Rollo ist der Hoffnungsträger für
all jene in diesem gespaltenen Land die
sich nach 21 Jahren in denen Präsident
Erdogans ackpartei an der Macht ist nach
einem Wechsel sehen
das Schicksal unserer türkischen
Republik werden wir nicht weiter in der
Hand eines Mannes lassen und wir werden
nicht mehr auf die Worte dieses einen
Mannes hören
killic daolo verspricht Erdogans
Präsidialsystem wieder abzuschaffen will
dem Volk und seinem Parlament mehr Macht
zurückgeben und seine Fans sind
überzeugt dass er diese Versprechen
einlösen wird ich liebe ihn denn er ist
ein unbelasteter und ehrlicher Politiker
steht für Rechtsstaatlichkeit er lebt in
einer normalen Wohnung aber hat es
verdient in den Präsidentenpalast
einzuziehen
beharrlich hat er ein Bündnis aus sechs
Oppositionsparteien geschmiedet das
wenige Tage vor der Wahl in vielen
Umfragen vorne liegt
Gürtel Tekken ist seit langem Jahren
politischer Wegbegleiter kiliterolus ja
sagte er viele meinten der Kandidat sei
ein bisschen grau und langweilig aber er
sei ein zuverlässiger Partner
war lange Jahre im Staatsdienst hat mit
vielen Regierungen und
Ministerpräsidenten zusammengearbeitet
sie können ihn nicht dazu bringen
irgendetwas zu tun das rechtlich nicht
in Ordnung ist Punkt
Gerechtigkeit forderte killic starolo
2017 auf seine Marsch von Ankara nach
Istanbul aus Protest gegen die
Inhaftierung von Partei genossen nach
dem Putschversuch ein Jahr zuvor endlich
publikumswirksam auf seine Forderung
einen Teil der dreieinhalb Millionen
syrischen Flüchtlinge in ihrer Heimat
zurück zu schicken
spätestens sind zwei Jahren und das ist
nicht rassistisch gemeint das will ich
hier noch mal betonen aber innerhalb von
zwei Jahren werde ich unsere syrischen
Freunde nach Hause schicken das will ich
hier noch mal deutlich sagen
kilica Rudow kann offenbar auch in
ehemaligen AKP Hochburgen Punkten Besuch
im Erdbebengebiet in adiamant viele hier
sind enttäuscht vom Krisenmanagement der
Regierung Erdogan davon will killic der
Rollo profitieren und er ist überzeugt
dass ihm das gelingt wir werden siegen
und diesem Land die Demokratie wieder
zurückgeben
um dieses Ziel zu erreichen setzt die
Opposition ganz auf ihn Kemal Kilic
daolo den Anti Erdogan
und über die Wahlen in der Türkei wollen
wir mit dem wohl promenten
prominentesten deutschen mit türkischen
Wurzeln sprechen mit Jim Özdemir
genannte ödemir guten Abend Frau Slomka
ihre Haltung dazu ist natürlich klar wen
sie sich wünschen wen sie nicht mehr
haben wollen aber wenn man sich jetzt
die dieses breite Bündnis ansieht das
gilt der Rollo geschmiedet hat reicht
das um wirklich stabils regieren zu
können wenn ihm ein Wahlsieg gelingen
würde
sind ja zwei Wahlen es ist die
Präsidentschaftswahl zum einen sie haben
gerade den Herausforderer porträtiert
und dann gibt es ja auch eine
Parlamentswahl und trotzdem die türkeien
Präsidialsystem ist muss beispielsweise
um die Verfassung zu ändern um wieder
eine parlamentarische Demokratie aus der
Türkei zu machen das Parlament zustimmt
dafür braucht eine Mehrheit sie haben
Recht er bräuchte in Sieg bei beiden
Wahlen bei der Präsidentschaftswahl als
auch bei der Parlamentswahl und dann ist
es Bündnis natürlich ein sehr breites
Bündnis man muss allerdings dazu sagen
so nah an dem Sieg war die Opposition in
den letzten Jahren schon lange nicht
mehr alle umfragen sagen das voraus und
werde gedacht dass die Stimmen aus
Deutschland mal so wichtig sein werden
für ein Erdogan
viele Kontakte in die Türkei sondern
hören natürlich auch was hier die
türkische Wahlberechtigte Community in
Deutschland sagt haben Sie den Eindruck
dass es da eine Stimmungsumschwung gibt
der bisher waren die aus Deutschland
wohnen Wähler ja sehr auf dem Linie
Erdogan auch die jüngeren
erstaunlicherweise
ja da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen
also sind 3,5 Millionen türkei-stämmige
ich sag bewusst Türkei stämmige weil die
definieren Sie hier sehr unterschiedlich
die einen definieren sich als Türken die
anderen als deutsche wieder andere als
deutschtürgen für wieder andere Spiel
die kurdische Herkunft eine wichtige
Rolle also um das korrekt zu formulieren
3,5 Millionen von denen 1,5 Millionen
sind überhaupt nur wahlberechtigt von
den wiederum sind bei der letzten Wahl
45% wählen gegangen davon wiederum haben
65% Erdogan gewählt also das relativiert
ein bisschen das Bild das alle
türkei-stimmigen pro Erdogan werden ich
z.B habe gar kein Türchen pass ich bin
türkische Herkunft ich kann in der
Türkei nicht wählen und davon gibt es
eine ganze Menge also bei denen die
Erdogan wählen das hängt sicherlich
damit zusammen dass dieses eben wir sind
wieder wer
die ganzen großen Welt kommen in die
Türkei und die Türkei ist ein Player des
Argument verfängt der sehr das hat
natürlich auch was damit zu tun dass wir
hier in Deutschland das Gefühl hat man
ist hier nicht anerkannt man ist hier
nicht Bürger das hat auch was viel mit
unseren Versäumnissen in der
Vergangenheit zu tun Stichwort
Staatsangehörigkeit natürlich auch in
der Türkei sagen auch viele Türken ja
Herr Erdogan der hat uns auch wieder
Wohlstand gebracht und wenn jetzt mit
der Inflation sieht das etwas anders aus
aber lange Jahre ging es ja für die
Türkei danach erstmal aufwärts also sind
sie sich so sicher dass es dazu einem
Wechsel kommt oder würden Sie sagen das
steht fifty fifty auf der Kippe
ich mir gar nicht sicher können wir uns
zeigen und dann kommt noch mal dazu wie
wird der Staatsapparat wie wird Erdogan
reagieren da wird ja auch bewusst ein
bisschen das gestreut und Wähler und
Wählerin zu verunsichern um sie davon
abzuhalten wählen zu gehen nach dem
Motto das wird sie sowieso nichts ändern
deshalb sollte man auf das narrativ auch
nicht reinfallen ich glaube man hat ja
in ihrem Bericht auch noch mal gesehen
dass auch aus der Anhängerschaft von
Erdogan diejenigen die ihn gewählt haben
wegen der Wirtschaft viele mittlerweile
skeptisch sind das Management des
Erdbebens hat es auch noch mal sehr
deutlich gezeigt dass eben ein Regime
Begriff eine Person sich beschränkt wo
Beamte nicht trauen selber aktiv tätig
zu werden weil sie auf Befehle warten
müssen dass das nicht unbedingt
angemessen ist aber hier in Deutschland
unterscheidet sich es ein bisschen unter
seinen Anhängern sind viele die eben das
alles nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen deshalb
höre ich auch Stimmen aus der Türkei von
vielen die sagen ist das eigentlich fair
dass Leute die gar nicht die
Konsequenzen ihres wahlentscheids
aushalten müssen bestimmen darüber was
in einem anderen Land in der Türkei
passiert man hatten die Grünen dazu
aufgerufen indirekt nicht Erdogan zu
wählen sondern für demokratische
Veränderung ist das klug wenn man die
Bundesregierung mitgestaltet wenn man
eine Außenministerin eine grüne im Amt
hat denn wenn er im Amt bleibt der Herr
Erdogan müssen sie mit ihm ja weiter
klarkommen
das ist so natürlich muss man mit den
Wahlergebnissen Leben Hauptsache sind
fair das muss man immer dazu sagen das
waren sie in der Türkei in der
vergangenen Jahr nicht unbedingt sind
sie auch jetzt nicht beim Thema
pressefreiheit ist die Türkei auf Platz
165 viel mehr Länder danach kommen nicht
mehr viele ihre Kollegen sitzt im
Gefängnis oder im Exil manche meiner
Kollegen im Exil oder im Gefängnis also
es ist nicht wirklich ein freier
Wahlkampf wie man sieht in der
Demokratie vorstellt in den staatlichen
Sendern kommt die Opposition sie gut wie
gar nicht vor trotzdem sagen alle
Umfragen Institute die Opposition liegt
gerade vorne das erklärt auch die
Nervosität und auch die ganz großen
Versprechen der Erdogan jetzt abgibt mit
Mindestlohn etc in jedem Fall ist eines
klar wenn die Opposition gewinnt wird
ein sehr schwierige Amtszeit werden die
Staatsfinanzen sind geplündert der
Staatsapparat ist durchsetzt mit Erdogan
Anhängern mit radikalen Elementen da
wird auch sehr stark auf uns ankommen
wir werden dieser neuen Türkei helfen
müssen Stabilität zu ringen
und auf dem Weg nach Europa
voranzukommen
und über die Wahl nächsten Sonntag wird
das heute journal live aus Ankara
berichten Christian Sievers meldet sich
von dort mit Gesprächspartnern und
Reportagen unter Montag nach der Wahl
sendet dann auch das heute journal
Update
und jetzt geht es bei dir erstmal Heinz
weiter Heinz mit anderen Themen und
Nachrichten in der Diskussion über
personalquerellen im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium von Robert
Habeck hat der Grünen koh-vorsitzende um
mit noripur darauf verwiesen dass es
jetzt Geld die Aufgaben in diesem Land
anzugehen im Interview mit der
ZDF-Sendung Berlin direkt äußerte sich
Nuri pur unter anderem zur Frage ob die
Entscheidung richtig sei den in der
Kritik stehenden Staatssekretär reichen
im Amt zu lassen
reichen hat einen Fehler gemacht
es hatte eingeräumt der Fehler war bei
der Besetzung der Spitze der Energie
Netzagentur und ist jetzt ab korrigiert
worden und jetzt gilt es dass die großen
Aufgaben in diesem Land und die
allergrößten liegen bei
Robert habe auf dem Schreibtisch jetzt
einfach weiter fortgesetzt werden und
angegangen werden
000 Kita-Plätze fehlen bundesweit 291
000 allein für Kinder im Alter von einem
bis drei so die Antwort des
Bundesfamilienministeriums auf eine
Anfrage der Linken Fraktion seit 10
Jahren haben Kinder ab vollendetem
ersten Lebensjahr eigentlich einen
Rechtsanspruch auf einen Kita Platz
im Sauerland ist die marode
rahmendetalbrücke der A45 kontrolliert
gesprengt worden das 17.000 Tonnen
schwere und bis zu 70 Meter hohe Bauwerk
stürzte planmäßig ein die Brücke an der
deutschlandweit wichtigen Nord-Süd-Achse
zwischen Dortmund und Frankfurt war seit
Ende 2021 wegen erheblicher Schäden
gesperrt der Verkehr wird seit dem
umgeleitet mit gravierenden Folgen für
die Region und die Wirtschaft wann genau
der Verkehr wieder ungehindert fließen
kann ist derzeit noch unklar der Brücken
Neubau wird voraussichtlich mehrere
Jahre dauern
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
IAA zeigt sich alarmiert wegen der
angespannten Lage um das ukrainische
Kernkraftwerk
saporicia-chef grossi erklärte die
Situation um das Kraftwerk werde immer
unberechenbarer und potenziell
gefährlich auch angesichts der von
Russland angeordneten Evakuierung einer
nahegelegenen Stadt in der der Großteil
der Mitarbeiter lebt das Kraftwerk liegt
frontner und seit über einem Jahr von
der russischen Armee kontrolliert
syriens Machthaber Assad kann zurück in
den Kreis der Arabischen Liga die
Mitgliedschaft Syriens war 2011 wegen
des gewaltsamens Vorgehens gegen die
eigene Bevölkerung ausgesetzt worden
heute stimmten die Außenminister der
Mitgliedstaaten bei einem Treffen in
Kairo für die Rückkehr Syriens
Bedingungen wurden nicht genannt aber
die Liga drängt auf eine Lösung der
Folgen des Bürgerkriegs wie die Flucht
von Syrien in die Nachbarländer und den
Drogenschmuggel in der Region
in der Nähe von Dallas im US-Bundesstaat
Texas hat ein schwer bewaffneter Mann
vor einem Einkaufszentrum um sich
geschossen und acht Menschen getötet
sieben weitere wurden verletzt ein
Polizist der zufällig am Ort war
erschoss in Angreifer hunderte Menschen
wurden aus dem Einkaufskomplex geführt
über die der Identität des Angreifers
und über sein Motiv ist noch nichts
bekannt
mit der Aufarbeitung der
Missbrauchsskandale in der Kirche stehe
man noch am Anfang sagte das
Zentralkomitee der deutschen Katholiken
gerade bei seiner
Frühjahrsvollversammlung von ihr werden
ja die Laien in der katholischen Kirche
repräsentiert die Gläubigen die sich
engagieren aber keine Ämter als Diakone
Priester oder Bischöfe inne haben unter
ihnen mehren sich die Stimmen die eine
stärkere Rolle des Staates bei der
Aufklärung der Missbrauchsfälle fordern
bislang sind es überwiegend die Kirchen
selbst die aufarbeiten was unter ihrem
Dach geschieht entsprechend der
Selbstbestimmung von
Religionsgemeinschaften doch zu oft ließ
sich beobachten wie solche Prozesse
verschleppt wurden die Täter und damit
die Institution geschützt wurden statt
Betroffenen zu helfen
über diese Debatte berichten Ulrike und
Christian Kirsch
der Staat ist verantwortlich für die
Durchsetzung der Grundrechte seiner
Bürger also auch der Kinder aber gilt
das auch wenn in einer Institution wie
der katholischen Kirche die körperliche
Unversehrtheit so verletzt wurde wir
wurden Opfer weil wir Katholiken waren
aber wir sind auch Staatsbürger wir sind
auch Träger von Grundrechten und diese
Grundrechte sind massiv verletzt worden
und es ist staatliche Verantwortung das
wenigstens im Nachgang aufzuklären und
aufzudecken
vor 13 Jahren kam der massenhafte
Missbrauch in der katholischen Kirche
ans Licht seitdem werden Studien
erstellt Gutachten präsentiert und
Kommissionen gebildet alles im Auftrag
der katholischen Kirche allerdings
bisher haben nur neun von 27-tümern
abschließende Ergebnisse präsentiert die
bis in die Gegenwart reichen das heißt
gerade mal Eintritt viel früher hätte
man zugreifen müssen auf die
Geheimarchive und die Akten die in den
Kirchen vorhanden sind und woraus sich
dann Straftaten ergeben können und auch
Straftäter das ist versäumt worden und
da trägt der Staat eine Mitverantwortung
für diese Dinge was wir brauchen ist
eine staatliche Stelle die bereit ist in
die Unterlagen hineinzugehen und die
dann das Ergebnis auch veröffentlichen
kann und der Gesellschaft und den
Betroffenen das Gefühl vermittelt dass
hier wirklich in Unabhängigkeit und mit
Freiheit im Zugriff auf alle notwendigen
Informationen ermittelt worden ist
in Deutschland sind Staat und Kirche
getrennt eigentlich doch der Staat räumt
der Kirche Sonderrechte ein
Religionsunterricht an Schulen Einzug
der Kirchensteuer Zahlungen in
Millionenhöhe basierend auf Verträgen
die tief ins 19 Jahrhundert reichen ein
kompliziertes Rechtssystem das so
Kritiker überholt ist und dennoch hält
sich der Stadt zurück auch die Deutsche
Bischofskonferenz fordert inzwischen ein
staatliches Aufsichtsgremium nicht nur
bezogen auf die Kirche sondern auch auf
Sportvereine und schulen damit wir sie
auch ihr Ansehen verbessern
weil wir immer unter dem Verdacht stehen
als die Organisation die für die Täter
die Verantwortung trägt dass wir da
Glaubwürdigkeit einbüßen wir müssen
dieses Missverständnis aus der Welt
schaffen dass diese Aufarbeitung nur
nach unseren eigenen Regeln laufen soll
das
Bundesjustizministerium teilt uns dazu
lediglich schriftlich mit die
Aufarbeitung des sexuellen
Kindesmissbrauchs wird das
Bundesministerium der Justiz sehr
sorgfältig prüfen dabei ist der sexuelle
Missbrauch in Institutionen insgesamt in
den Blick zu nehmen
die Aufarbeitung sexualisierter Gewalt
in der katholischen Kirche ist voller
Versäumnisse weil Täter gestorben und
Taten verjährt sind das Leiter
Betroffenen jedoch verjährt nicht mehr
staatlicher Beitrag zur Aufarbeitung ist
überfällig
und jetzt macht heißt noch mal weiter
mit dem Sport an diesem Wochenende
zunächst zur Fußball-Bundesliga da hat
Dortmund 6:0 gegen Wolfsburg gewonnen
Dortmund bleibt damit knapp hinter
tabellenspitzenreiter Bayern mit einem
Punkt Rückstand auf Platz 2
beim Tennis Masters Turnier von Madrid
hat Jan Lennart stuff den
Überraschungssieg verpasst im Finale
unterlag der 33-Jährige aus Warstein dem
spanischen Titelverteidiger Carlos in
drei Sätzen
in Großbritannien feiern viele Menschen
weiter das neue Königspaar vor Schloss
Winzer findet am Abend ein
krönungskonzert statt mit Stars wie bei
einer Richie und Take That auf den
Straßen traf man sich heute zum
traditionellen big Lunch ein großes
gemeinsames Mittagessen manche zog es
dafür in die Downing Street zum Sitz des
Premiers andere ans oder aufs Wasser
Königstein
heute aus dafür gaben sich andere Royals
volksnah morgen dann Zeit zum Erholen
für alle an einem zusätzlichen Feiertag
und damit sind wir dann auch schon beim
Ausblick auf die nächste Woche den hat
uns Kamera und safiariant
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
am Dienstag wird Russland den Tag des
Sieges über Nazi Deutschland feiern
traditionell mit einer Militärparade auf
dem Roten Platz vor 78 Jahren besiegte
die Sowjetunion Hitler Deutschland und
besiegelte so das Ende des Zweiten
Weltkrieges
landesweit wurden wegen des
ukrainekrieges und dem drohnenabschuss
am Kreml einige Paraden abgesagt
am Mittwoch werden sich Vertreter von
Bund und Länder zu einem
flüchtlingsgipfel im Kanzleramt treffen
Städte und Kommunen erwarten vom Bund
einen Neustart in der Flüchtlingspolitik
und fordern mehr finanzielle
Unterstützung bei der Unterbringung und
der Integration von Flüchtlingen und
Asylsuchenden am kommenden Sonntag
werden die Türken einen neuen
Präsidenten und ein neues Parlament
wählen
Oppositionsführer Kemal Kilic staoglu
will die 20-Jährige Herrschaft von
Präsident der Recep Tayyip Erdogan
beenden eine richtungsweisende Wahl für
die Türkei und Europa
ebenfalls am Sonntag will die Hansestadt
Bremen eine neue Bürgerschaft SPD
Bürgermeister bodenschulte regiert in
einem für Westdeutschland einmaligen
Bündnis mit den Grünen und der
Linkspartei jetzt wollen er und sein
Herausforderer im Hof von der CDU
jeweils stärkste Kraft werden
und so geht es beim Wetter in die neue
Woche die Aussichten morgen von
Schleswig-Holstein bis nach Sachsen viel
Sonnenschein in der Südwesthälfte schaue
und Gewitter dabei im Süden auch mit
Starkregen die Temperaturen liegen
zwischen 16 und 22 Grad in den nächsten
Tagen wiederholt Schauer dabei auch
Blitz und Donner mit Temperaturen
zwischen 12 und 22 Grad
das war's von uns an diesem Sonntagabend
um 0:25 Uhr heute Express und hier
erwarten Sie morgen Christian Sievers
und Hanna Zimmermann auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]